[Música]
nuevo bloque económico de nuestra mañana
en directo América Daniela Blandón vamos
a empezar a hablar de Brasil porque ya
se eligió un nuevo presidente Luis sin
anunció Luis Ignacio Lila le pregunto
qué ha dicho en la campaña sobre por
supuesto el tema económico Hola Raúl
Pues con su Victoria Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva de 77 años volverá como andar
la mayor economía de América Latina ha
prometido atraer inversión extranjera
restaurando primero que todo la
credibilidad de Brasil como
administrador de la selva amazónica
donde la deforestación se ha disparado a
un máximo de 15 años en la campaña
presidencial
prometió acabar con el hambre que hoy
afecta a unos 33 millones de personas y
Buscar fuentes de trabajo en una nación
con más de 9 millones de desempleados
también promoverá una reforma tributaria
para reemplazar cinco gravámenes con un
solo impuesto al valor agregado o IVA y
tiene la intención de eximir de
impuestos a las rentas de hasta 5000
reales o 1900 972 dólares por mes y
elevar también los impuestos de los más
ricos también le cuento Raúl que el real
de Brasil amaneció este lunes perdiendo
más del 2% frente al Dólar y el
principal índice de la bolsa de Sao
Paulo del IVA Vespa comenzó la jornada
en rojo Bueno vamos a cambiar de tema
Dani porque las petroleras de Estados
Unidos dispararon sus ganancias Pues en
las más grandes Raúl presentaron
resultados el viernes pasado
correspondientes al tercer trimestre con
pocas sorpresas en medio de la creciente
demanda y un mercado de energía
desabastecido el principal productor de
petróleo de ese país y uno de los más
grandes del mundo que de sexo móvil casi
triplicó sus utilidades frente al tercer
trimestre del año pasado a medida que
las exportaciones de gas y de petróleo
de Estados Unidos a Europa se han
disparado como una manera de reemplazar
el menor suministro ruso lo cerca de 20
mil millones de dólares que ganó casi
igualan las ganancias de Apple y le
dieron tal impulso Wall Street que su
capitalización de Mercado subió a un
máximo histórico Hablamos ahora de
Chevron petróleo que es otro de los
Gigantes de Estados Unidos estuvo a
punto de duplicar su beneficio fue
exactamente de 11.200 millones de
dólares su segunda ganancia trimestral
más alta de la historia y con esto
revivieron las críticas del gobierno
bailén desde luego el presidente volvió
a arremeter contra esta industria en
Twitter dijo que las empresas están
utilizando estas ganancias
récord para pagar a sus ricos
accionistas en lugar de invertir en
producción y reducir los costos para los
estadounidenses y lo terminó calificando
de inaceptable vamos con otras noticias
económicas del día Dani Pues el Disney
Resort de Shanghai suspendió
abruptamente sus operaciones este lunes
para cumplir con las más recientes
medidas de prevención de covid 19 en
China en redes sociales abundaron los
videos de visitantes en el momento del
anuncio tratando de salir ya que la
orden es permanecer en hasta que de
negativo en la prueba del virus también
se ha conocido que la producción de
iphones de Apple en una importante
planta de fabricación podría caer hasta
un 30% el próximo mes debido a estas
restricciones
la tasa de inflación interanual en la
eurozona aumentó en ocho décimas en
Octubre y se ubicó en 10,7 lo que supuso
un nuevo récord en la historia de este
grupo de países según datos preliminares
de la oficina estadística comunitaria
eurostad la principal subida de los
precios se registró en la energía con un
41,9%
finalmente los precios de los contratos
a futuros sobre el trigo subieron un 6%
en las primeras operaciones del día en
Chicago y el maíz aumentó más de un 2%
en el primer día bursátil después de que
Rusia anunciara su retiro del acuerdo de
exportación de granos del mar Negro lo
que genera preocupaciones sobre los
suministros mundiales cifra del día Dani
90% Raúl de los paquetes turísticos
procedentes del extranjero han sido
cancelados en los últimos 38 días en
Irán según la asociación de transporte
aéreo y agencias de turismo esto como
consecuencia de las protestas desde la
muerte del 16 de septiembre de mcminí
tras ser detenida tres días antes por la
policía de la moral eso por llevar mal
puesto el velo islámico Dani como
siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica mañana con más